[Musique]
hot dog frites au montreal pool room non
ce n'est pas de la gastronomie mais une
rencontre avec de jean louis heroes dont
les quartiers du strip tapissent les
murs de ce restaurant plus que
centenaire de montréal
puis le patron et mais ça c'est ça
une émotion dire
des cartes réalisées avec son associé
torontois des années 80 qui ont marqué
le début d'une longue carrière de
cartographie du strate heures dont le
nom est probablement plus connu à
singapour en arabie saoudite ou en
colombie britannique que dans son pays
natal tout jeune il était doué pour le
dessin je faisais des caricatures des
tic avec sur les professeurs ce qui lui
a valu quelques ennuis une fois trouvé
sa vocation il s'est lancé ma carte dans
le bunker était la première près gtl gnl
ça les a surpris que québécois avec
l'accès depuis
qu'ils trouvent les commanditaires il
représente rolex piaget pts et yves
piaget lui-même reste ajouté ces petites
touches personnelles humoristique si tu
chies que tu étais dans la sphère
tournesol passent par la gare comme
avait historique de lénine qui a
séjourné à genève et sigma chili ni
messi ni s'est fait expulser mais
l'ironie c'est que menace ces quatre là
de genève il vendra 500 francs suisses 2
703 parce que c'est sûr maintenant un
item de nostalgie
après genève montréal sur le même modèle
de commanditaires
de la peau camier odm et martin et puis
c'est plein de petits trucs comme ça
il est né à montréal
champlain est là qu il admire
ingrat et rossi samuel de champlain
c'est lui qui a fait vraiment la
première carte de l'amérique du nord
l'art est très ancien
[Musique]
les cartes étaient souvent illustré de
monstres marins
d'être fantastique
de cannibale
ceci va devenir quai cale avec baston il
ceci va devenir ma natte sa d'y revenir
jean louis a réalisé des cartes
commerciales touristiques industriels
aussi comme celle des grands lacs un
travail de moine qui commence à la main
avec une esquisse comme celle des grands
lacs transposer ensuite dans
l'ordinateur pour la finition le tiers
supérieur de cette carte de la vallée
d'okanagan a été fait tout à l'aquarelle
le reste à l'ordinateur ça prend
beaucoup d'aces caisse au crayon avant
d'arriver à déchets alors ça vous prend
combien de temps pour faire une heure ça
ça peut roumaine
aller travailler dessus tous les jours
et au recteur tous les jours le ter
d'une coche en se les robes légères il
ya les édifices qui ont été dessinés
avec et d'étain comme les voitures des
fois mes gardiens comme 800 à des fois
des gauchistes faire il ya des projets
en cours en arizona après santa fe le
lac powell la ville de paige et puis une
commande pour le territoire de la nation
navajo
une carte des émirats arabes unis pour
l'anniversaire du chèque l'a amené à
l'arabie saoudite et à la mecque où il a
illustré les étapes du hadj dans le
détail un séjour prolongé à anchorage en
alaska à cause du 11 septembre 2001 l'a
conduit à faire de sa carte un casse
tête oui de nos jours les cartes
routières sont un peu démodé mais pas
les siennes car l'internet est arrivé
les gens
mais le gps c'est pour montrer comment
sera 24 s'illustrer c'est pourquoi veux
tu rendre
jean louis rault n'est pas près
d'arrêter il a des projets en tête à
commencer par un rafraîchissement de sa
carte de montréal qui a bien changé
depuis la dernière fois
[Musique]